[Music]
i know we've talked before about like
senior pranks or just kind of things you
uh have gotten away with in school yeah
this one i think takes it pretty far
there's a florida high school where
someone had hung a massive dead shark
from the rafters in front of the
courtyard that's pretty hilarious
what's the the mascot oh how the [ __ ]
the sharks do that the ponte vedra
sharks where do you even get a [ __ ]
shark from that's crazy they had to go
catch it they had to go haul it the
mascot was really a shark yes so was it
like a rival high school that like
grabbed a dent in mine oh god is that a
great white i don't think they know yet
who it is they know it was five students
maybe it was on camera you can't tell
about the dorsal fin you can't [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with your
computer you want to see it that [ __ ]
close that's crazy they got a shark
where you get a shark like that that's a
big ass shark someone went deep sea
fishing someone had to fish someone had
to catch it and then gut it they got it
enough so that you know you could
[ __ ] get it that high then they just
uh where's
oh my god there's something terribly
[ __ ] sad about that like that's
really fun hopefully there's already
down on the beach right we all hope that
right guys i do hope that yeah sometimes
that happens does that happen a lot of
florida i'm just sad that they
they just let that flesh rot instead of
eating it oh shark fin soup thank you
why catch it if you're not gonna do
anything i mean
yeah i mean it is it's just killing it
and just hanging that's [ __ ] up man it
is an emptied carcass it's not really
like full of all the goods i think oh
really it's just skin senior pranks are
dumb as [ __ ] that's what i think well
empty cars is like the meat's all still
like it's still body you know i mean
it's still a life that was [ __ ]
murder for the sake of a prank you know
what i mean pretty [ __ ] heavy prank
dude that's [ __ ] up somebody knows who
this kid is you can't [ __ ] move a
shark like that yeah people it's a team
dude it's gotta be there's i think five
students are uh
the ones that were like caught on camera
doing it and and they're they're going
an investigation out to figure out which
five they are and then those guys will
not get but everybody knows they won't
walk yeah and they won't go to grad
night that's how they who do you think
he's gonna rap well the the pita kids
let's say that like in your own high
school whether it was a big big or small
if something like this happened you
instantly know who the [ __ ] did
everybody know yeah if it wasn't how big
is the graduating class because they've
been given they always catch them
they've been giving you signs the whole
year they're like dude did you see how
the size of the fish i caught last
weekend yeah but that's why that's why
i'm wondering if it's like a rival
school because i remember rival high
schools would do that to each other and
stuff so it's like if the mascot's a
shark and then you go [ __ ] put a dead
shark up it's kind of like yeah [ __ ] you
show is that during homecoming or is
this during [ __ ] senior week and they
usually do differences they do it with
the theme that makes
fun of them so at our school at cerritos
high school their rival was gar and they
would come garbage so they would go and
just throw garbage in that car yeah so
it'd be like dead sharks or some [ __ ]
you know what i mean
you know like the old school movies like
they would always steal the other like
mascot or like
do you guys ever did you ever go to a
school that did [ __ ] like that
senior praise what was the cerritos
mascot the dawn the dawn how do you do
that how do you like you still love
italian man
hey i'm walking in you pick him up steal
him [ __ ] hanging from the raptor hey
somebody get me down from here
you [ __ ] kids almost teddy am i gonna
make my spaghetti
you want i should take myself down from
here
it'd be funny to like you know like
mayfair had like the typhoons or
something oh let's simulate a
class nine storm that is a good high
school prank
yeah a storm simulator that's fire dude
doing it in one day though kind of
hacked in my opinion what i did yeah was
i did over several months
what you're a mastermind though you've
always been a mastermind thank you my
senior prank was well me and me and my
buddy every chick that ever like denied
him and there was like a lot of them
we uh 30 chicks we went to costco we got
those 500 um boxes of fork you know like
those boxes of forks that have 500
inside of it yeah we bought like four of
them 2004s
and we and we would go fork in people's
lawns
but specifically the chicks who who
denied him yeah so it's pretty classic
so like you know it's like this little
bit of revenge and for me it was just
[ __ ] hilarious
putting
when they step outside in the morning
did you see [ __ ] white all white
forks like stuck-up prongs like all over
their [ __ ] lawn like all over which
side the fork side of the handle so the
handle's down right and the fork sides
up
so does that do damage to property or is
it just like it's just annoying i don't
know to this day because i never went
back you don't go back to the scene
you just the the imagination's fun
you're like giggling like oh that's
creative i think you get points for that
because it's like it's kind of harmless
it doesn't really in your head is it
like they're just like barefoot walking
outside not paying attention and
stepping on problems no they because
they walk away you respect the walkway
right you don't hurt anybody you just
want them to see it you just want them
to know that they they shouldn't have
turned him down
you missed out
that's the best part you could have been
with us we could have been forking
someone else together yeah yeah so the
batteries got forked we did that like a
bunch of times like four times before
the end of the year but at the end of
the year we hit them all on the same
night and we called it the festival
forks
and then how long did it take you guys
to sit there and
put forks in the front lawn all night
long and nobody ever saw you doing it
nobody ever calls once asked me how hard
i was laughing while you were doing it
the whole time i was laughing the whole
[ __ ] thing to the point where you
almost got caught i couldn't [ __ ]
breathe
i was busting so hard
how did you do how do you put so many
forks down that's really funny though
that's harmless you never took a photo
or any like anything like that no how
did you know when it was like enough
he's doing like a japanese guy at a rice
pad he's just
that's it he has a machine
and we did it all night so we did the
festival for we hit all those houses at
the same night right he must have been
the good old boys of the neighborhood
they didn't even like care to get you in
trouble you know because it's such a
it's such a weird one i think people go
outside like what the [ __ ] happened yeah
the [ __ ] is this or they just they're as
they're walking out they realize kind of
like within like 20 seconds it's easier
to clean that up than tp yeah which is
their face like who
did this
they're just like looking around that's
the best part but
at the end of the year in our senior you
know when you get to write a little
thing we put
um festival forks both of us did
to take to take responsibility nobody
even knows nobody even knows this
[ __ ] day nobody ever called it out
that was a multiple month plan
damn but that's very creative thank you
i thought i like a prank that's a little
harmless but it's just it's really funny
you know like in those tv shows or like
movies right they always get like a car
like the principal's car was it saved by
the bell they get the car and then they
put it on the top of the [ __ ]
gymnasium or some [ __ ] and i'm like how
did they do that they have budget yeah
did they get a crane like
dude mario lopez was jacked they have
production bunches mario lopez was so
strong on the show yeah he's just jacked
he lifted that car just canceled the new
they just did a news tape by the bell
and then they just canceled it just now
yeah it's not as good i mean nobody none
of us even knew what was happening you
would run into like a script corner if
you didn't just automatically solve it
it's like mario lopez remember when they
crashed the car
they crashed like i think it was uh one
of the girls cars and then and then uh
slater just fixes it
just fixes it without any explanation
didn't even go by parts or nothing we
were so much more dumb back then totaled
luxury cars he was gearing up he goes he
just goes all right but it'll take me
all night
the next [ __ ] day new bumper
everything and they don't even address
how he did it and it was the cool
transition it was the sixth transition
this transition goes from the car [ __ ]
up with ben with the tree and then
slater going like this in the next one
and then put
what about the episode where the girl
with the curly hair she got addicted to
caffeine yeah i was just thinking about
that i'm so excited
because she had to study for her
midterms i'm so scared
did that do anything to help you uh not
dude never did caffeine again after that
it's funny because i was like caffeine
and i was like isn't that antique you
take caffeine pills i took caffeine
pills in uh in college when i was trying
to study there's a thing called nodos
maximum strength caffeine
like scary cause like you i would for
because i for me when i'm tired i need
to fall asleep i pass out i don't have
the strength i can't do one of those
like i would do all nighter on my own
right so i'll take a caffeine pill but
then at like four in the morning while
i'm trying to cram for [ __ ] i'll just
pass out my body will give out because
i'm too tired but then because in me
when i wake up i'm like
my heart's pumping like crazy and it
just happens every like five minutes
it's it was it was really terrible so
you go to sleep but the caffeine's still
working yeah and it'd wake me up and
i'll be like shocked and i try to like
read some more and then like 30 minutes
later like pass out again like come back
oh yeah i gotta reheat yeah but it'd be
like heart attack kind of you know
that's what i think like five hour
energies do to me it just gave me a
faster heart rate but it didn't
necessarily give me energy oh damn it
just gave me like anxiety
five hour anxiety yeah that's one of
those things you gotta be that's a good
brand dude five hour anxiety i mean yeah
maybe some people want anxiety i would
love some right now i like the
experience of like being able to sip my
monster and like having enough because
like with the five hour it's like gone
yeah it's going down right i think
that's what [ __ ] people love the most
yeah like when you down it too quick
then you're like
you gotta it's like very dose depending
on like yeah we used to download those
before every show and it was like okay
you can get through the show just fine
but like you're not performing any
better you just like feel like you're
supposed to you're just awake yeah it's
a ritual it just fuels your intention
but it doesn't feel
like the craft itself yeah yeah yeah
your mental conviction's stronger
because you just feel like you're
panicking your mental conviction is
strong because you're panicking that's
why you know i would suggest different
alternatives like you know bart's
pre-workout barbell brigade it's a very
good free workout because you know
what's funny hey i will say this though
like this is not a sponsor a lot of
dancers actually take free workouts
great it's not a sponsored thing at all
but like the first time i took
pre-workout totally [ __ ] me up it felt
like 30 hour energy and then i tried
bart's thing when he just gave it to me
and i was honestly a little bit scared i
was like dude he's gonna [ __ ] me up but
i was like [ __ ] it i'll try it and it
was fine you take the whole dose you
accidentally gave me the whole thing you
go i usually take half and then you hand
it to me i started drinking it and then
you went oh that was a whole one
and i was like you take half with your
body weight and you gave me a hole you
know why bart went to a [ __ ] rain
forest he found the botanicals that make
that possible
i thought i was just his case study no
he had it took a long time honestly the
supplement the ingredient list is
supplements it's not just caffeine but
it was honestly it was fine like it was
good you know i had a great workout i
didn't feel like a [ __ ] crazy guy
after his course
bar was picking leaves and the five
hours
energy makes me feel like a [ __ ]
vietnam vet dude
he just hears fireworks oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you